me
皆さんこんにちはヘッジアレイの岩佐と申します
5年前に私の子今日である宮城県山元町は津波による被害で
人口の4%が
一気になくなってしまって町の特産品であった
イチゴのハウスのほとんど
95%が破壊されてしまったんです
その時にあまりにも悲惨な光景だったのでこれは高目に焼き付けておかなければいけ
ないと
これから何か人生で何かがあったときにこれを思い出そうと思って撮った写真がこの
写真ですほとんどのものが破壊されつくしてしまったというのが5年前の光景です
私自身は19歳で故郷を離れて東京に出てそして24歳の時に it ベンチャーを
起業しました
10年間東京でこの時にはすごく好成功してお金もを設けて時にはこう失敗して効果音
を失いっていうそういった行為
エキサイティングな10年間を過ごしていてちょっと今この冊子を見るとだいぶ今より
も高目つきが悪いなというふうに思うんですけどやっぱりこう
多分もお金をかけるとかねそういったおそらく10年間だったのかなというふうに今
思ってます
そしてその震災の後にどうしてもその国境芸何かをやりたくなったんですよね
その子今日って失ってみてそのなんか重要さというのが初めてわかるもんだなと思って
たぶん自分の肉体っておそらく皆さんに行く際もそうだと思うんですけどもおそらく
故郷の空気や
が水や土から皆さんの肉体って作られていると思うんですよね
だから小香が破壊されるとまさにこう自分が破壊されたような感覚になってしまったん
ですね
もちろんすぐに何かやれるかって言ったら何もできないのでまずはこうボランティア
活動から始めようと思って5年か前に小境に戻った時の写真がこの写真なんですね
でこの時にはそれまでほとんど数年に1回ぐらいしか故郷に戻っていなかったんです
けども
このボランティアきっかけに毎週故郷にへ戻るようになって急にねその子今日っていう
のが身近なものに感じたっていうのが5年前の今ぐらいのことでした
何をやろうかと思ったんですけれども
ここの名産であったイチゴを復活させて世界一の産地賞というふうに当時考えたんです
ねそこで高農業生産法人を作ろうと思って
創業時に関わってくれた一緒に創業してくれた共同創業者がこの三人ですね
一番左側が橋本洋平君と言ってから当時私と同い年で隣の中学校で35歳
彼は津波で自分の娘さを流されて死んでしまったわけですね真ん中の年老いた方は橋本
忠次さんといって彼はイチゴ作り40年の大ベテランだったんですね
その地元でも頑固一徹で有名で素晴らしい個作りてだったという高橋本ただ潰さ
この3人で私たちはこう農業をスタートしました
もちろん高農業をスタートするときにこう土地が必要ですから
へ
道は堂々2箇所見つけなきゃいけないと
橋本洋平君というのは私がこう東京に出てからもずーっと公庫今日で働いていたので
故郷のことは知り尽くしているわけですねそして彼はあっという間に甲土地を見つけて
くれて最初に建てたハウスがこの今写っているハウスです
ハウスを作るのは
東京からたくさんのボランティアの方に3 ik まで来てもらってそして私がお金を
かき集めてきてなんとかこうハウスを作ったというのが
5年前の話です
もちろんこうイチゴを作るためには技術が必要なんですけれどもそれはこの農業40年
橋本忠次さんのこの匠の技で1年目からこう大豊作だったわけですよ
大豊作だったんですけれどもちょっと待てと
私がここに来て農業をやろうと思ったのはここ
地域を盛り上げるためで彼だけがイチゴを作れてもしょうがないわけですね
したがって彼の担当経験を形式知化して
形式知にして若い方にどんどん伝承していかなきゃいけないっていうふうに思ったん
ですねまで箸持たずさんとディスカッションしていると彼はこう言ったんですよ
苺っていうのは
人に教えられるもんじゃないとしかも人から学ぶ者でもなくて
イチゴと会話して覚えるもんだっていうふうに彼は言ったんですよ
僕はねその次の日にイチゴ農園に行ってなんていうかその子供に照明類 f みたいな
そんな感じのことを言ったら当然そのこうなんか全然片手刀がないわけですよ当たり前
なんですけども返答が来てそして橋本篤に聞いたとやっぱりそれは難しいじゃない
かって聞いたら
彼が言っ
たのはもう今でも捨ててないですけどもう15っていうのは女性と同じだとお前女に
もてないだろうと言われたんですよね
いやいやーも出ている人が思ったんですけどもあのまあそういったあのーことから
イチゴづくりを飲まなんて言ったんですけれどもやはりその匠の技というのは以心伝心
だけで若い人に伝えていくというのは限界があってできたとしてもすごく時間がかかる
のでちょっと違う方法を使わなきゃいけないということで私がこう得意分野だった it
と農業というのを結びつけるということにこうチャレンジしたんですねこの時に行こう
vr を使って若い農業者に1
この作り方を教えようというシステム私が作っている時に初めてこの橋本忠次さんが
コンピューターに興味を持ったわけですよ
これすごいなとでこれでコンピューターを覗き込んで
これ面白いかもしれないと
でこのシーンが来るまで1年くらい私は我慢して彼のオールドウェイというかね
伝統の技をに従ってやってきたんですねここで思ったことはやはりこう年長者から何か
を得るためには若い人っていうのはある程度我慢しなきゃ
てないってことだと思うんですよねそして若い人が
年調査は若い人の考え方を受け入れる寛容さっていうのを
もちろんおもちゃなきゃいけないっていうわけですねそして世代と違う世代と違う世代
がつながった時にできる価値っていうのはこれものすごい価値が生まれるわけで
我々はこう絶対そのゼネレーションの新しい違うネーションのぶつかり合いっていうの
を避け情けちゃいけないと思うんです
宝鋼
なんかこう2つ入っちゃいけない言葉があって
なんか室はあの親父とかという言葉がマズイっちゃダメでもう一つはやっぱりこう最近
の若い者はって言う風な言い方は
要望しないようにしようっていうことで彼はぜひ皆さんやりましょうということなん
ですけれども
そうこうしているうちにこう匠の技と it が組み合わさって非常にその素晴らしい
イチゴができたんですね
私たちはこれをミガキイチゴというふうに名付けたんですねそして東京に得て最初に
売られたんですけども
入ってビックリしたのが一つ1000円で売られていたんですねでそれでもどんどん
どんどん売れていったと
これはやはり古いものと新しいものをつなげるっていう事やはりすごい価値を生むんだ
っていうに確信したんですねそしてそれから山元町という私の子今日は人口
1万2000人ぐらいしかいないんですけども
今では年間2万人くらいの観光客が世界中から
匠の技と愛
ティーガー組み合わさって農業みようということで来てくれてるわけなんですよね
下がって世代間のつながりそして地域を超えたつながり
こういったものは常にこう新しいものを生み出す可能性があるんじゃないかなと思って
います
時に違うものがぶつかる時ってすぐ混沌とした雰囲気になる
ですけれども混沌がないイノベーションっていうのはおそらくないと思うし
イノベーションっていうのは必ずの混沌としたものを通過していっているはずなんです
よね
ですか皆さん何かこう日常ですごく気に食わないことがあったり
なんかもやもやしたら
それではもしかするとイノベーションの入り口に入りかけているんじゃないかと
すごく私は思うようになりました
実は
この私がやってきたことっていうのは古郷を持っている
皆さんだったらどなたでもできることなんですよねでも市小境がない方だったら皆さん
の愛してる人の子今日だったりあるいは尊敬している人の子橋にいって挑戦をすれば
いいと思うんです
で今日私
から皆さんに一番伝えたかったことは
故郷へ帰ろうリターリングフォームっていうことを皆さんに伝えたいと思っています
一度でも故郷を離れて外で何かに挑戦した人だったら誰でも準備はできていると思い
ます
最後の
写真ですこれはインドの写真なんですけども見てください
あの頑固一徹人に位置も作りは教えないと言っていた橋本た家族さんが写真の真ん中に
いて
インド人に笑顔でイチゴ作り教えているんですよね
で
彼の口癖は社長次のインド出張はいつなんだっていうのは彼の口癖なんですけども
なんで彼がそんなにインドに行きたいのかなということを私は分からなかった
でこの時初めて彼と一緒に出張してわかったのが橋本忠次は今やインドではレジェンド
と呼ばれてるわけですよ
ああああああ
でほとんども神様みたいな赤穂に扱われて
で食事なんかもう全部こう上げ膳据え膳ですよ
もちろん全部カレーですけどね劣化やとの抗加齢を毎日食べながら
インドの貧しい人にイチゴづくりを教えてるっていうことなんですよねしたがって東京
と地方が繋がっ
たそして古い世代と新しい世代がつながって今度は故郷の技術が海を越えてインドに
まで行ったっていうのがこの5年間の出来事だったんですね実はそのその後年間に私は
何をしたかっていうと
ただその故郷に帰っただけなんですよね
それ以外何もしてなくてそこで必死にがんばっていたっていうそれだけだったんですね
そして皆さんももしへ
大変忙しいと思うけれども
たまには小境に帰って
こ今日の土をあるいは空気を水を感じてみて
そして古い友達と話してみてください
もしかすると皆さんの新しい人生の扉が開くかもしれないと思います
小境に帰りましょう
り turning 本園部位ティガーがフライングてくださ
ありがとうござました
me